but right now I turn the phone lines and
find a friend of the program and a
friend in general and one of the best
that bleach report puts out there for
sure to give us all news and information
and there's a lot of talk about Odell
Beckham potentially being on the move
still that that rumors been out there
and it seems to be gaining a bit of
steam and to talk about that and the
rest of the NFL Draft that's coming up
from Bleacher Report Mike Freeman how
are you Michael very good first I gotta
say what you do with the draft and st.
Jude and I mean it's really amazing and
I just want to make sure I got that said
that - you haven't said that's here yet
it's FedEx Mike you do and it's very
appreciated and the what Beckham ever
beat he may never be traded but it's
this stupid poke go away well why why do
you think why do you think that rumor
won't go away Mike it's because some of
it is because when I spoke to people
about some of his because they don't
think he's a perfect fit in that office
they think he's not they don't think
Baker Mayfield was that accurate of a
passer and that will tend to frustrate
Beckham and that chemistry isn't quite
there you saw some of that some of the
chemistry was lacking last season that's
because they're so new together and that
could really improve this year and they
have a real head coach this year so all
of that could really dramatically change
very quickly but it's just it's his
feeling and I think it's a wrong one a
wrong one rich that Beckham can't get
along with anyone I don't think that's
necessarily true I don't think he's that
bad a guy everything he's a hard worker
he's very talented he does but he has
this perception in the league that he is
a troublemaker and can't get along with
people and they think that situation
there is explosive potentially I don't
I'm not sure I don't know I just I feel
like he gets a little bit of a bad rap
but I also think that there's some truth
to it that he's not a perfect fit with
that quarterback in that offense but
this year this is a big year we'll see
this year what happened Mike Freeman a
bleacher report here in the Rich Eisen
show and you know what
yeah I know he you know screamed at
kicking nets right and we all know right
that he was part of the famed boat crew
the days before a huge playoff game the
Giants last playoff game that they
played in Green Bay and then punched a
hole in the wall etcetera or so on and
so forth but again I've heard the same
thing to Mike that that his teammates
love him and that they they get a big
kick out of him
and that when when he scores and he
makes a big play that just there's few
players in the NFL that can when they
make a big play can lift the entire team
so the question is is what what what are
you hearing is supposedly the bad mix
between him and and Mayfield it's not
it's not that there's any kind of
personality clash it's just that Baker
Mayfield has some problems with accuracy
and there's well he will he be able to
get better at that and just connect with
Beckham that's the big issue but hitting
on some but you hit on there is dead-on
about his teammates in New York a lot of
the players really liked him in
Cleveland a lot of the players really
liked him he's very well liked in that
locker room and appreciated and what you
when you talk to teammates about him is
I've done repeatedly they'll tell you
first thing they'll tell you is how hard
he works and how supportive he is of
people around him and how the media sort
of blows up some of this stuff but yeah
this is this is gonna be I think
constantly around because of beckham's
personality it is explosive and the
belief that he's not a great fit there
that will this season will determine
where that goes where that goes this
year will determine and that that Brown
team could be really good they go so it
could be this season will determine
where where and when Beckham where he
goes how long he stays in Cleveland if
he stays for a long time you stays for a
short time I guess you could say Mike
that the the annual video remember every
team used to have like a video that
would come out for the season you know
the Browns video going in is this Browns
team could be really good and then then
the video coming out as the Browns team
could have been really good and then
that's the issue so what do you think
the odds are that this guy does get
traded it's got to happen one would
think in the next 72 hours right you've
got to be able to take whatever you
whatever you get and plug it right into
a very deep draft certainly at the wide
receiver position well I think the odds
overall are pretty small
I think the Browns want to give this
another season and see what happens when
you have a really good offensive system
give give those to Beckham and Mayfield
more time together and then see see how
that goes you just don't want to really
just give up on a guy like that so
quickly so I think the odds are small
but when the Browns say there's no way
we're doing it like don't believe that
team's always say that he's always say
there's no way we're trading this guy
and then they trade them so not
necessarily what the Browns say though I
tend to believe them it's more just they
don't want it they think this guy's
really good and they want to see what
happens with one more season with them
together and see how it goes and if it's
what I think it could be then he won't
go anywhere for a while but if you see
that lack of chemistry again then it
could be an issue and I'll just say this
real quick rich one of the things that's
happening now is we saw this a little
bit 20-30 years ago ten years ago a
little bit where teams were very
hesitant to trade star receivers they
were just just it happened I mean Randy
Moss got traded you saw some of that you
saw thrill Owens change teams but a
teams were still hesitant to do it
because of the vaulting passing game how
important receivers were and now there's
so many good receivers they're not as
afraid anymore
they're they were they're willing to get
rid of I mean Houston's a little bit of
a different situation because that
situation is crazy but still there you
will see that there are still teams
there are teams that are saying I'm not
as married to this great receiver I will
take a chance with him though that she
better draft or free agency and it's
been like that and it's changing the
receivers are still obviously huge
because the passing game is so big in
the NFL but they're not as afraid to
make a move with some very talented
wipeouts as they once were well I think
maybe that is because wide outs maybe
start to be viewed as as running backs
not in the fact that you know that once
you're past the age of 30 you've
outlived your usefulness you know
although because there are some we've
seen Emanuel Sanders make a nice signing
even coming back from a blown out
Achilles at the age of 30 continuing to
do what he's doing but we're seeing guys
come out of college and just to get
things done and get him done fast and
this this this year's group is really
deep Mike Freeman here on the Rich Eisen
show running backs we've seen what
running backs can can be coming out of
college and that makes running backs
even in their second contracts somewhat
fungible and replaceable so what's the
scoop with Leonard fournette here in
Jacksonville clearly I think that this
is the the whole concept of him saying
let's go get Cam publicly is just the
tip of the iceberg for this team and for
net what do you have for me on this
front Mike that situation rich has
always been a little bit tenuous because
Frenette you point out that good example
of him let's go get ya that's not
optimal for team they don't want you
saying let's go get this guy when they
decided we're gonna go at another guy
when that speaks his mind and there's
and there's something bigger though the
Jaguars are rebuilding they're
completely restructuring that team and
we just talked about the receivers
there's there is still a belief that the
running backs are not a key part of this
game and not as much that you can just
going back to what you said which is
dead on our receivers I can be used as
running backs you can just throw a quick
pass out to them dump it off to them and
they can be devastating for more
devastating than
I'm running backs not in every case
obviously there's great running backs
that can do a lot Christian McCaffrey
can do a lot but the receivers are ten
can function in that role to tight ends
can function a lot in that role so teams
just still look at backs and I think the
Jaguars are this way and say we can find
someone that we like more that's maybe
cheaper that we don't that we believe in
and we're cool with and we're gonna
focus on the receivers and the
quarterbacks and backs are replaceable
but that's what's happening in
Jacksonville I just sure I just think
for summary I don't know what it is but
Coughlin is gone now but I I just think
that both both sides are kind of sick of
each other I don't know you kind of get
that yes right yeah and there's no
there's a couple players in Jacksonville
who have and and the team they're sick
of each other there's other players on
that roster and the thing about it is
I'm a huge Jaguar guy I love that
organization
I like that owner a lot I like the way
it's run so I think they what they're
doing is I it's risky because you're
basically starting over but I like what
they do overall as an organization I
love that city I love that area and so
they're just they're deciding let's just
we're just gonna move on from these guys
who may not want to be here and we'll go
and we'll build our own franchise the
way we want to build it and if you don't
want to be here if you top it of being
here well goodbye
see you later and I think they're headed
so you thinking Gok ways one of those
obviously he's one of those guys do you
think he will be heading out I mean
because there that that's that's
something that bears in mind before we
see the draft play out this weekend
right he's basically he's basically said
it so not basically so I think he's yeah
you're gonna see which I think there's
there's a couple of these situations to
really watch he's one of them so mr.
choices in JAC with the Jaguars maybe
Beckham but I doubt it and a couple
other guys a couple of situations
where
you could see trades and moves it's
always this way with the draft but it's
really sort of shaping up that way this
year
and and I would just really watch the
Patriots I know we say this every year
Paige is always we always say they're
gonna make some kind of big move
I just speaking of people around the
league who find it hard to believe the
patron I go into this year with those
two quarterbacks no offense
they just find it hard to believe that
that's what they're gonna do and they're
not thinking like five years down the
road they think the pictures are going
to make some kind of big move a
quarterback so watch them and and the I
can't find anyone who thinks the bengals
are not going to get burrow that no
matter what they're offered they're
sticking with him they think he's the
kind of guy that can energize that
entire city so unless someone does like
a Mike Ditka entire draft ideal they're
not moved they're not budging either so
they're a couple things that are fixed
they're a couple things to really watch
and like always as you know this draft
something that we never planned on an
unexpected will definitely happen
well that's let's dive in a little bit
on the Patriot thing because that's so
intriguing obviously because it involves
the Patriots and Belichick and Brady and
what happens in the next step and so on
and so forth
you don't think Stidham has impressed
and behind the scenes enough to have the
Patriots just say we're all in with this
kid you don't think that's the case
nobody believes it might be no it might
be what I'm saying is people don't
believe it I mean I have tremendous
respect for bells like he's the best
coach never do it that organization is
to me just my opinion the best in the
history of the league you're gonna see
though what it looks like as like
without Tom Brady I mean he he you know
you talk about a tide lifts all boats I
mean he was a tsunami and he'd better
that organization in every way he will I
they relied so much on him obviously
with the passing offense obviously the
office but he impacted every corner of
the organization one guy and so what I'm
saying is teams are saying you're gonna
go from that to what you have now
anyone who follows Brady would have a
hard time but this is a particularly
really brutal transition and no one
believes the pictures are going to do
this they just don't believe it now the
Patriots and Belichick is he's a very
confident guy he may say yeah we're good
with this and he may roll the dice and
that that the odds are that's probably
what will happen he says that no one
believes it because how does a guy go
from brady to to this and not really
thinking more about adding more talent
and a roster at that position and taking
a chance with moving up with some of
these players and draft this year or
really good so this is more question if
they don't believe it but i don't think
is that kind of guy they'll take is that
guy who will say I like him he's
impressed us we're gonna roll the dice
it's just that no one really please Mike
Freeman of bleach report here on the
Rich Eisen show so you know we keep
talking Jameis and cam and for good
reason because in Jameis you got the guy
who threw for 5,000 yards and he's got a
big arm and he seems to have turned his
life around and has his head on straight
and his LASIK done and you've got cam
who's a former first overall pick who
was entertaining an iconic in Carolina
as he said he would be but I don't know
why I'm just keep sitting here so much
Mike and thinking once burrow gets
drafted Dalton's got to go somewhere and
that's when Dalton's gonna start coming
to this mix and he might be the one that
gets the gig in Jacksonville obviously
Jay Gruden's there so on and so forth I
wonder what you think about that
quarterback carrousel going into the
draft totally agree with you and all
that I think Cam Newton has gotten one
of the Ross deals and that I've ever
seen
a guy who was just physically just
battered his whole career the
organization walks away from him and
there's this perception and part of his
because of these times were in doubt
that it's hard to just get a real
hardcore physical on guys because it's
just what we're facing but there's a
fear of his his health his his body
breaking down I think whoever
get symbol get a massive steel I don't
feel strongly about Jameis Winston I
feel that way bearish to only about
Camden
I think he's got another really strong
really impressive chapter to write and
whoever gets him whoever gets him is
going to get a huge bargain but I think
I agree with everything you said I think
teams are going to go with Andy Dalton
first and we talked about some of these
things I could happen in a draft this is
one of those things that will probably
we'll see some type of deal in the draft
a team that doesn't necessarily you
mentioned a Jaguars that's a possibility
there are other teams who don't get the
drafted player they want so they go for
Dalton and then after that or guys like
ham and then after that is Jameis to me
I agree with you cam I mean you want to
talk about a chip on his shoulder and
his foot I mean you know right he's got
the chip coming in and he's got and he's
still Cam Newton you know III know he's
not gonna plow people through you know
on third and short anymore unless he
unless he's back healthy and I know he
does have such a cannon our Matt here
mails people but there's just something
about I mean he still Cam Newton and and
he'll put Fanny's in the seats um I'm
just interested but the Chargers have
such a need for somebody like him maybe
they're sitting back waiting if - it
drops to them and they come out with -
uh then - it checks the box of the
futures now come get your tickets
everybody knows who to is he's a delight
so on and so forth maybe that's what
they're waiting for with the charges
what do you think well you hit on I
think one of the big things with cam I
think there's a lot there's a good half
dozen teams that or have him on their
radar and are looking to see what
happens in the draft and some of these
dominoes will fall on the drafts and
some of them may not a little bit after
but I think he's one of the Domino's I
could fall because I I do think I the
way he has been at times portrayed and
treated as always irritated me but there
are teams that
No he still has a lot left and there are
teams that look at him and value him and
think he's very very good still so it's
just that some of them just aren't they
are willing to make a move now because
they want to really get a good look at
him physically and also they want to
wait and see what happens with the
quarterbacks in the draft but eventually
there's there's teams out there that are
sort of waiting watching him monitoring
with him and I'm gonna make some moves
maybe for a younger player in a draft
but they're there he has a lot of
interest there's a lot of teams that
really respect him and respect his game
respect him as a guy respect his work
ethic all of that so those teams out
there I just wish he had then I mean
look this happens with the NFL the big
boy League it's brutal at times the way
guys are treated as brutal at times I
just wish he was treated a little bit
better more respectfully because he
deserves it he's earned it he's been a
really good player in his league a
really good citizen in his League
and there's still again rich there's
still a lot left there he's still got
some game left last one for you Mike
Freeman your best guest by the end of
Thursday night who's got Herbert who's
got two and who's got love by the end of
the night and if you think there's a
fifth one in the mix maybe I think that
the Alphin still get to I think the
Patriots have Herbert and I don't I'm
not I'm still not sure where that third
die goes I still like love to New
Orleans they have a guy that could be a
future QB but love is a perfect kind of
Sean Payton guy so I think this is
there's not going to be a whole lot of
shocks with the quarterback I got to
tell you Herbert to the Patriots is a
shocker how do you how do you think he
slips 223 or Belichick actually makes a
move because he does have a ton of last
day pick
and he does have a lot of late Friday
third rounders but other than that
there's not much capital to get up to
where he might need to get to Herbert
the odds of it are slim right yes but it
goes back to what we were saying before
I just the people I really respectively
find it hard to believe that he's going
to go into the league go into the season
with what he's got and think he's gonna
make this is a year he makes a big move
so but the odds of that he just may not
have enough to do it he may have no
interest in doing it it's just kind of
what people are saying that's what they
think that this is the year he finally
makes really a huge move he probably
won't it's just not what he does in
general but if he was going to do it
this is a year so so I say that sort of
knowing the odds of it are slim but
there's just I've been I've been really
talking to a lot of people last like
five or six days pretty intensively and
that's sort of one of the big standouts
as they think the pitcher is going to
make some kind of big move for chibi and
but but odds are it's gonna go pretty
straight forward like who you think is
gonna go where that's what will happen I
don't buy I don't buy the Dolphins
aren't interested in - I didn't I didn't
go for that head fake at all but you
know the Joe judge Jo judges
interviewing Herbert by zoom that one
was that one was like what now own just
left me with a head scratch what are the
Giants just putting it out there hey
we're sitting there at four if you want
Herbert you might need to come to us I
mean like what what was that about that
felt fake that felt like Jim Kirk and
Star Trek doing like the corporal might
went over just google it okay
google it google it that felt fake that
felt like some kind of poker moves that
that's like 3d chess but no one's
falling for it no I mean so the corpora
might just for people to know it is it
is just a total fake it's a Fugazi right
but the Kobayashi Maru is - is to game
the system to cheat
get what you want so maybe that's that's
that's who's pulling on Kobayashi Maru
and in in the draft
what are you got for me there gentlemen
is try gentleman is trying to pull Oh
Kobayashi Maru but it's coming out to be
a fake Corbin might all right everybody
Google those things mic live long and
prosper man thanks for joining
appreciate it thanks appreciated back at
you there you go I just gave you them
just gave everybody throw it up throw
out the spot talk to the spot hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here